one of the great mysteries of brexit has
always been what the Labour Party's
position on this is certainly the
membership of the party overwhelmingly
supports staying in the European Union
but their leader Jeremy Corbyn is quite
another question through his entire
political career as a renegade
left-winger he'd been the euro skeptic a
great danger so the course of socialism
in this country or in the other country
the imposition bankers Europe but by the
time the brexit referendum happens he'd
done what looked like a half-hearted
about turned Labour Party is going to be
committed to campaigning to stay within
the European Union for the last three
years the party membership has tried to
convince itself that Corbin is on their
side no longer the problem for Corbin
isn't only that voters find his position
on brexit confused
it's that throughout his entire
political career he sets himself up as a
conviction politician prepared to go out
on a limb to try to break the mold of
traditional politics so much ambiguity
of a brexit seems to fly in the face of
his own idea of himself
activists forced a motion calling for
the party to unequivocally support
staying in the European Union there's
this idea that somehow we're going to
wait until after the election 10 that
we've got no position now and then sort
of but we'll definitely campaign if we
remain in the future and everybody
accepts that will definitely campaign
for a man in the future I'm sorry but I
don't think that treating voters like
they're idiots is a vote among the
conference delegates such as a support
for Corbin that speaker after speaker
urged them to vote for his position
which is not to decide on a brexit
policy until after he becomes prime
minister they won and then separately
the pro EU side lost if there's a moral
to the story of the day it is surely
that the membership of the party people
not in this room have not had their
views reflected by their own leaders and
that does not bode well for Corbin
Lawrence Lee Al Jazira that Labour Party
conference in Brighton